this next one I think is very near and
dear to many of the folks in this room
and that is the tale as old as time
Beauty and the Beast you know it this is
a big magical musical and yes it is
usable that features under the
leadership of the very talented director
Bill Condon who did dream girls one of
the very best casts we have ever
assembled Emma Watson is absolutely
stunning his mouth I hope you caught a
glimpse of the yellow dress and the
sizzle at the top of the show dan
stevens stars as the beast Luke Evans is
Gaston Emma Thompson is mrs. Potts Kevin
Kline plays bells father Maurice Ian
McKellen Josh GAD stanley tucci ewan
mcgregor Audra McDonald google and Botha
raw it is like a fairy tale now Emma
really wanted to be here today in person
but as I said they are hard at work in
London but she did send a message from
the set just for all of you at d23 hello
everyone today 23 we have had an
unbelieving time shooting two beasts
bringing out life of me has been a
complete dream come true I can't wait
veteran certainly 2017